[Música]
como espera a vladimir putin hacer
frente a las sanciones internacionales
tiene el presidente ruso algún plan para
ganar la guerra económica con qué
activos cuenta exactamente rusia para
disputar esta batalla porque el rublo se
desplomó tras la invasión pero luego al
poco tiempo recuperó prácticamente todo
su valor quiere decir a caso de esto que
el kremlin se está saliendo con la suya
queridos amigos amigas en este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas así que arranquemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la guerra de ucrania la cruel y
despiadada invasión de ucrania no solo
está siendo una enorme pesadilla en el
campo de batalla también está teniendo
un impacto económico mucho mayor del
esperado y particularmente en el caso de
la economía rusa nadie moscú imaginaba
que las cosas en 2022 fueron a ir tan
mal lo que se anunció como una operación
especial se ha terminado convirtiendo en
una intensa y pesada guerra con un
gigantesco coste en términos de vidas
equipos y recursos de todo tipo una
guerra que también ha desatado una
reacción internacional de tal calibre
que ha superado cualquier plan de
contingencia manejado por el kremlin
en pocas semanas tras la invasión rusia
se convirtió en una especie de país
paria y aislado con gran parte del
espacio aéreo mundial cerrado a cal y
canto para sus aviones con las empresas
internacionales huyendo despavorida
excluidos en gran medida del sistema
financiero internacional y cargando con
un montón de restricciones comerciales
tan sólo en moscú son decenas y decenas
de miles de puestos de trabajo los que
ahora están en peligro por la salida de
las empresas multinacionales y no lo
decimos nosotros lo dice el propio
alcalde de la capital rusa fijaos según
nuestras estimaciones unas 200.000
personas corren el riesgo de perder sus
puestos de trabajo sérguei sobiánin
alcalde de moscú tras desatarse la
tormenta de fuego en ucrania el panorama
para la economía rusa se ha vuelto
tenebroso a medida que las sanciones han
ahogado las importaciones que muchas
empresas rusas están teniendo que
reducir sus operaciones por falta de
suministros que cientos de empresas
occidentales están abandonando el país y
que miles de rusos están perdiendo sus
puestos de trabajo la economía rusa se
está tan
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea según el
propio banco central de rusia el pib de
este país se desplomara al menos un 8%
en 2022 una previsión que el banco
europeo para la reconstrucción y el
desarrollo eleva hasta el 10 por ciento
el banco mundial por encima del 11 por
ciento y el instituto de finanzas
internacionales hasta el 15 por ciento
hablamos en cualquier caso de la peor
recesión en rusia desde principios de la
década de 1990 y ojo porque hablamos tan
solo del primer año a medio y largo
plazo son muchos los analistas que
apuntan a que las cosas se pondrán aún
peor mucho peor las mejores estimaciones
que estoy viendo salir ahora mismo
sugieren que la economía rusa va a
recortarse a la mitad de lo que era
antes de esta invasión del ipp singh
asesor adjunto de seguridad nacional de
los eeuu habrá menos inversión menos
comercio internacional menos integración
de rusia en las cadenas de valor
mundiales y esto combinado con la gente
que abandona rusia significa un menor
crecimiento de la productividad a largo
plazo beata llavorsí economista jefe del
banco europeo para la reconstrucción y
el desarrollo ahora bien retomemos las
preguntas que nos hacíamos al principio
como espera vladimir putin hacer frente
a las sanciones internacionales qué plan
tiene pues bien lo primero de todo es
saber exactamente cómo se encuentra
actualmente rusia y que ha caracterizado
la etapa de putin al frente del timón
atentos pero un momento antes de
continuar
los precios de la electricidad el
petróleo y el gas están por las nubes
llamados récords de 14 años por culpa
gran medida de la falta de inversión y
bajo semejante contexto la invasión rusa
de ucrania ha sido algo así como el
remate por eso ha comenzado a extenderse
una pregunta podría el hidrógeno llegar
a sustituir al gas ruso que empresas y
países están liderando esta nueva
revolución energética no te pierdas el
vídeo que han hecho en si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
participamos os dejamos el enlace abajo
en la descripción y ahora sí continuemos
un nuevo zar para un imperio en
decadencia
os lo hemos contado en varios vídeos
aquí en visual político la caída de la
unión soviética y la transición a una
economía de mercado fue de todo menos un
camino de rosas la mala gestión
económica la corrupción galopante las
finanzas públicas casi quebradas y por
último una gigantesca crisis financiera
hicieron de los años 90 una década
dramática para rusia por ejemplo entre
1990 y 1998 el pib per cápita real de
los rusos se desplomó más de un 40 por
ciento y eso que el punto de partida no
era precisamente para echar cohetes pues
bien de semejante debacle surgió
vladimir putin se convirtió en
presidente en el año 2000 prometiendo
poner en marcha un amplio proceso de
reformas para modernizar el país
empezando por supuesto por la economía y
eso fue exactamente lo que hizo al poco
de llegar al poder el gobierno de putin
puso en marcha el llamado plan craft un
plan que buscaba atraer inversores
en cierto modo el plan greg fue todo un
éxito si la corrupción siguió por las
nubes pero las cosas en rúsia mejoraron
mucho el gobierno ruso impulsó la
privatización y la desregulación de
amplios sectores de la economía se buscó
atraer a los inversores internacionales
y se estableció un impuesto fijo sobre
la renta del 13% un flat tax que hizo
que putin ganaran muchos puntos en la
comunidad económica internacional el
caso es que estas reformas junto con los
crecientes precios del crudo dispararon
el ingreso per cápita ruso desde los
2000 dólares hasta un máximo de 16 mil a
comienzos de la década del 2010 un
despegue que por supuesto multiplicó la
popularidad de putin dentro y fuera de
rusia
[Música]
el problema es que la reforma se
terminaron muy pronto entre los años
2002 y 2008 los precios del petróleo se
multiplicaron prácticamente por 4 esto
hizo que el gobierno ruso pasara ya de
las reformas de hecho más bien el
fenómeno fue exactamente el contrario
poco a poco la economía rusa fue
pivotando más y más en torno al kremlin
al tiempo que la corrupción seguía por
las nubes y los sucesivos planes de
reformas que se presentaban nunca
llegaban a ponerse en marcha esto junto
al hundimiento de los precios del
petróleo 2014 y con sanciones tras la
invasión de crimea hicieron que las
cosas seguirán la vuelta fijaos en este
gráfico
si miramos la participación de rusia en
el pib mundial la situación 20 años
después de hacerse con el poder había
regresado al punto de partida si los
rusos son los más ricos que en el año
2000 pero no ha mejorado más de lo que
ha mejorado el resto del mundo y lo que
es mucho peor la economía rusa cada vez
está más dominada por grandes empresas
ineficientes y corruptas cuya actividad
depende fundamentalmente del favor del
gobierno esto es lo que explica por
ejemplo que rusia básicamente sólo
exporte materias primas
[Música]
desde luego todos absolutamente todos
hemos podido ver el enorme impacto que
tiene la corrupción en la desastrosa
actuación del ejército ruso en ucrania
sea como sea el caso es que ahora con
las sanciones aprobadas contra este país
tras la invasión de ucrania las cosas
prometen ponerse mucho pero que mucho
peor y como veis no parece que a rusia
llegue a esta crucial batalla en su
mejor momento la economía rusa está
repleta de corrupción más allá de las
materias primas sus empresas son muy
ineficientes y tanto el consumo como la
propia producción local dependen en gran
medida de suministros internacionales
hasta ahora quizás lo mejor que ha hecho
putin ha sido mantener a raya el gasto y
la deuda pública sobre todo tras la
invasión de crimea cuando el kremlin
entendió tras recibir las primeras
sanciones que tener unas cuentas
públicas saneadas y muchas reservas
internacionales era algo necesario para
disputar la guerra económica
y es que amigos amigas en 2014 el
gobierno ruso comenzó a desarrollar un
plan de contingencia que ahora tiene que
aplicarse por completo un plan en el que
juega un papel clave esta mujer que veis
en pantalla elvira nabiúlina sí vale lo
sé es la típica imagen de un oligarca
con cara de malo pero esta mujer
encabeza la contraofensiva con la que
putin quiere ganar o al menos resistir
la guerra económica que los aliados han
lanzado contra rusia atentos
la mano derecha de putin en la economía
rusa
ganar la guerra en ucrania y evitar el
colapso económico estos son los dos
objetivos que se ha fijado el gobierno
ruso como una prioridad absoluta pues
bien elvira nabiúlina la gobernadora del
banco central de rusia es uno de los
actores clave para conseguir el segundo
objetivo
nabiúlina que procede de los círculos
liberales de rusia ha sido una de las
manos derechas de putin desde que éste
se hizo con los mandos del país primero
fue viceministra de desarrollo económico
y comercio en 2007 fue ascendida
administra de este mismo campo hasta el
2012 luego ejerció como la asesora
principal del presidente para asuntos
económicos y desde el 2013 ocupa el
cargo de gobernadora del banco central
[Música]
algo que por cierto hace con mucha más
autoridad de la que tienen la mayoría de
sus homólogos internacionales porque en
a violín a lo controla todo las finanzas
la política monetaria los seguros los
fondos de inversión la banca de las
reservas del gobierno en el terreno
financiero es probablemente la persona
más importante de toda la rusia y
también la gente rusa con mayor
prestigio internacional durante años su
objetivo fue estabilizar el rublo y
combatir la inflación algo que hizo con
mano de hierro llegó a cerrar 500 bancos
elevó los tipos de interés muy por
encima de los cánones internacionales y
liberalizó el rublo para promover la
integración de rusia la economía
internacional claro que también acabó
alentando la nacionalización de casi el
70 por ciento del sistema bancario ruso
pero eso es otra historia el caso es que
ahora sus metas han cambiado por
completo durante años el banco central
hizo todo lo posible para ayudar a rusia
a integrarse aún más en la economía
mundial entonces de repente el 24 de
febrero tuvo que hacer todo lo contrario
andrei moves and ex ejecutivo de banco
ruso y actualmente financiero en londres
amigos putin la acaba de renovar para un
tercer mandato y ya es ahora la
encargada de liderar la respuesta
económica de rusia la pregunta es qué ha
hecho para preparar a este qué está
haciendo y qué pretende hacer atentos
[Música]
la contraofensiva económica del kremlin
podemos dividir la respuesta rusa en dos
partes las medidas de corto plazo y la
estrategia para hacer que la economía
rusa resista durante los próximos meses
e incluso años si tal y como parece el
castigo se prolonga en el tiempo en esta
línea desde el 2014 lo primero que hizo
el gobierno ruso fue incrementar sus
reservas extranjeras e incrementar el
peso de activos como el yuan o el oro y
posiblemente esconder una buena parte de
ellas y si lo habéis escuchado bien se
sospecha que el banco central de rusia
ha podido esconder lejos del alcance de
las sanciones internacionales decenas de
miles de millones de dólares en cuentas
offshore opacas se habla de hasta 80 mil
millones de dólares en títulos de deuda
del gobierno de los eeuu escondidos a
través de empresas superpuestas en
lugares como las islas caimán o incluso
bélgica donde tiene su sede euro crear
una de las compañías de custodia de
activos más importantes del planeta
[Música]
también se especula con que el banco
central de rusia ha podido acumular en
sus propias bóvedas unos 30.000 millones
de dólares en efectivo contante y
sonante y el caso es que todo esto le
podría dar cierto oxígeno al gobierno de
putin para seguir operando en el mercado
internacional por ejemplo podrían auto
comprarse la deuda externa de rusia por
una fracción de su valor o pagar
importaciones o inversiones críticas
luego por otra parte nada más aprobarse
las sanciones internacionales y el banco
central ruso respondió con un paquete de
emergencia que incluye una subida de
tipos hasta el 20 por ciento más tarde
fijados en el 17 y la imposición de
fuertes controles de capitales
por ejemplo se limitaron los retiros de
las cuentas bancarias en divisa
extranjera se estableció un impuesto e
incluso para algunos casos la
prohibición temporal a la compra de
moneda extranjera y se obligó a las
empresas exportadoras a repatriar y
convertir a rublos el 80 por ciento de
sus ingresos en el extranjero también se
prohibió a los inversores extranjeros
liquidar sus posiciones en la bolsa de
moscú o recibir el pago de dividendos o
intereses
incluso el día 9 de marzo del gobierno
suprimió el impuesto sobre la compra de
metales preciosos digamos que si los
rusos querían proteger sus ahorros y no
se fiaban del rublo que compraran oro en
el mercado local en lugar de dólares
libras o euros pues bien según sberbank
la demanda de oro se cuadriplicó durante
las primeras semanas de marzo el
objetivo amigos de todas estas medidas
era frenar a toda costa la huida de
capitales y con ello el hundimiento del
rublo algo que temporalmente la señora
nabiúlina consiguió aunque eso sí el
precio fuera hacer del rublo una moneda
intervenida y prácticamente inútil en el
panorama internacional en cualquier caso
dos en estos controles de capital junto
al desplome de las importaciones lo que
explica que el rublo se disparará
durante el mes de marzo hasta recuperar
su valor previo a la invasión
[Música]
claro que si tienes una moneda tan
intervenida tampoco tiene mucho mérito y
desde luego no impide el resto de
efectos sobre la economía local por
ejemplo dejar de importar componentes
reduce si la demanda de dólares pero
puede suponer que muchas empresas
locales se terminen viniendo abajo
pensadas que el rubro de la unión
soviética- que no valía prácticamente
para nada tenía un tipo de cambio
oficial de 0.6 rublos por dólar de la
misma forma que el peso argentino
también tiene un tipo de cambio oficial
y luego otro tipo de mercado que es muy
pero que muy distinto sea como sea estas
son las medidas urgentes pensadas para
el corto plazo pero la pregunta es que
espera hacer rusia si esta situación se
prolonga durante años pues amigos lo
primero ha sido anunciar que en el
futuro se exigirá que el pago de sus
exportaciones de materias primas se haga
en rublos al mismo tiempo que el banco
central ha establecido un precio fijo
para las compras de oro cinco mil rublos
por gramo de oro y la pregunta es todo
esto para qué
pues veréis como hacerse con rublos hoy
por hoy puede no resultar tan sencillo
ni tampoco deseable para los gobiernos y
las grandes multinacionales la idea es
que éstos terminen pagando sus compras
en oro el cual se intercambiaría en
rublos al precio fijado por el banco
central a ver no se trataba a pesar de
lo que están diciendo muchos medios de
comunicación de volver al patrón oro ni
nada por el estilo porque la moneda rusa
no será convertible en ningún caso pero
digamos que es una forma de fortalecer
el rublo incrementar las reservas de oro
rusas y muy importante atacar el sistema
de los petrodólares esto es la compra de
petróleo utilizando la divisa del 'tío
sam' algo que se considera como uno de
los cimientos del valor del dólar y que
países como china ya están intentando
emocionar el problema de todo esto es
que al final rusia puede terminar
vendiendo muchas menos materias primas y
también teniendo muchas menos divisas
extranjeras con las que operar en el
mercado internacional pero bien luego
por otro lado el gobierno ruso parece
estar preparando una estrategia para
comprar las acciones rusas y los activos
en manos de los inversores extranjeros
por supuesto con un fuerte descuento la
idea sería algo así como crear un grupo
de campeones nacionales grandes empresas
que se hicieran prácticamente con todo
vamos potenciar aún más lo que ha sido
la estrategia de control económico de
putina seguido en los últimos años
también se está planteando que luego
algunas de estas empresas puedan cotizar
en mercados offshore donde puedan
recaudar dinero de inversores de países
menos hostiles de países como china o
las petromonarquías del golfo pérsico
haciendo que estos inversores pues no
corran el riesgo de sus acciones
[Música]
por último el kremlin ya ha anunciado
que reforzará la política de sustitución
de importaciones apoyando con
financiación barata a las empresas
nacionales al tiempo que confía que
países como china e india pueden
terminar siendo todo un salvavidas para
su economía incluso espera que las
sanciones no vayan mucho más allá o se
den pronto la vuelta aunque sea
parcialmente en moscú entienden que el
mundo no estará dispuesto a prescindir
de sus materias primas
pues bien querida comunidad visual
político este es el plan de putin
aislarse de las economías occidentales
fortalecer su divisa con el oro
recuperar los activos nacionales y
confiar en que china la india y otros
países similares puedan funcionar como
un salvavidas suficiente como para
capear esta tormenta
claro que esto puede resultar más fácil
de decir que de hacer hoy por hoy no
parece nada fácil que el plan de putin
pueda tener éxito rusia está cada vez
más aislada de la economía mundial y tal
y como ya vimos aquí en visual político
es posible que ni siquiera china venga a
su rescate solo sentiremos el impacto
real cuando las líneas de producción se
rompan la mayor parte de lo que se
produce en rusia depende de componentes
fabricados en occidente y así sin estas
piezas el trabajo se detendrá en las
fábricas de automóviles en la
perforación en altamar en la aviación
etcétera natalia psuv arevich economista
y geógrafo rusa tampoco podemos decir
que nos sorprendan los planes de putin
en materia económica llevan mucho tiempo
sin funcionar en los últimos años la
economía rusa ha ido de mal en peor
desde su máximo de 16 mil dólares el
ingreso per cápita ruso había caído
hasta el entorno de los 12.000 antes de
la invasión de ucrania y ahora con las
sanciones todo apunta a que caerá muy
por debajo de los diez mil dólares esto
supondría una contracción de casi el 50
por ciento desde que el gobierno ruso a
un lado las reformas y puso en marcha su
agenda más nacionalista y despótica
[Música]
y todo apunta a que los rusos van a
pagar muy caro la agresión contra
ucrania sobre todo si los países
europeos y el resto de aliados comienzan
a reducir las compras de petróleo y gas
ruso si eso se produce y tenemos en
cuenta lo dependiente que es la economía
rusa de ventas energéticas entonces el
colapso sería con mucha diferencia el
escenario más probable digámoslo alto y
claro no hay plan que pueda soportar un
impacto semejante pero llegas hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que la economía rusa
conseguirá sortear las sanciones
internacionales puede la guerra
económica desatada por occidente llegar
a tumbar al régimen de putin durarán las
sanciones el tiempo suficiente deben los
países aliados incrementar su castigo
hacia rusia déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios ya sabes si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante no olvides darle
al botón de like y por supuesto
suscribirte a visual política una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]